bonsoir jean lain la capelle merci des
histoires en direct sur rt france
l'union européenne qui incite donc à la
réouverture des frontières en vue de la
saison estivale
votre réaction il faut que l'europe et
n'arrête de s'obstiner de toujours se
prendre pour un état elle n'est pas un
état et elle a démonté d'ailleurs dans
sa capacité à coordonner les nations
européennes qu'elle est absolument
incompétente donc que je crois que ceci
est un sujet concerne cher pays dans
chaque nation qui doit pouvoir en
fonction de la gravité et l'ampleur ou
non de la crise sanitaire qui doit
pouvoir réguler ses frontières c'est une
mission régalienne et depuis le départ
nous estimons comme tous les bidons que
chaque nation d'emploi contrôle et avoir
la maîtrise également de ses frontières
pour réguler et bien les flux de
marchandises comme les flux de deux
personnes et c'est le cas dans le cas de
cette fille solitaire c'est le cas aussi
dans le cadre de la régulation des flux
migratoires donc union européenne
s'occupe un peu plus de ces affaires
quelle est sa liberté au pays en
fonction de ses spécificités et de ses
contraintes bien de gérer elles mêmes la
régulation le contrôle de ses frontières
ils prétextent sur la base de tourisme
en effet warner et obey les frontières
mais le tourisme de de son tir de nos
frontières donc tous les pays du monde
il ya des frontières dans tous les pays
du monde et le tourisme donc il s'agit
simplement de pouvoir réguler ensuite et
bien les flux de personnes pour assurer
une sécurité sanitaire dans un premier
temps et puis également pouvoir
contrôler les flux migratoires et en les
oublis union européenne a reçu a été
extrêmement incompétents également alors
effectivement il s'agit de deux cent pro
condamnation en tout cas de la part de
l'exécutif européen l'espagne en tout
cas déjà dit aujourd'hui selon deux
sources au ministère espagnol des
affaires étrangères qu'elle
maintiendrait ses frontières fermées
jusqu en juillet il n'empêche ya
beaucoup d'allées venue de flux au sein
des frontières de l'europe l'été des
français qui vont en espagne et vice
versa ce qu'ils ne recevraient pas
souhaitable sur ce point tout même
d'harmoniser un petit peu les choses par
son fier aussi de clarté tout simplement
parole
citoyens européens français et hop mais
ce ne sera pas possible je comprends
l'intention mais chaque pays doit avoir
la liberté de pouvoir
on n'est pas le bilan la situation n'est
pas la même dans chaque pays je rappelle
tout de même vieux l'europe puisque vous
parlez de l'avant dans votre sujet des
états unis qui est l'homme qui est
extrêmement touchée par la mort
mais l'europe est le premier continent
touché frappé il ya plus de soixante
mille morts en europe
et quand vous comparez le nombre
d'habitants en europe 1 sud est des
états unis
c'est là que vous apercevez de la
gravité en quelque sorte du bilan de
cette crise chaque état a en revanche
bien alors une graduation aux
différentes dans la gravité dans
l'ampleur de cette crise est nié tout
laisser chaque état il faut lui laisser
sa liberté de pouvoir fermer ou pas les
frontières il il s'agit pas bien sûr de
stopper le tourisme mais il ya bien des
frontières aujourd'hui en france on l'a
on impose aujourd'hui un périmètre de
100 km autour des français pour aller
travailler on les a confiné pendant 50
jours chez eux c'est bien de frontières
autour de l'appartement ou de leur
maison qu'on a mis en place mais de la
même manière il ya des frontières qui
s'appelle les frontières nationales qui
malheureusement n'existe plus qui ont
des dettes restaurer partiellement
pendant cette crise sanitaire et bien il
faut continuer à les faire vivre
mais l'union européenne n'a pas réussi à
rappeler vous a coordonné la fermeture
des frontières au début de la crise est
la mi temps en temps à réagir
et là en même temps on avait encore des
vols et des avions qui provenait de
chine qui arrivait encore sur notre
espace début mars alors que nous étions
déjà en clans la crise alors que
l'italie était déjà un pays qui comptait
de nombreux morts tous les soirs mais
l'union européenne ce qu'elle n'a pas
réussi à faire hier ses doigts pas
comment elle avait à le faire demain
donc elle laisse la liberté la
souveraineté et son indépendance
à chaque pays pour gérer ses missions
régaliennes alors c'est vrai que les
économies nationales vous le savez sont
en chute libre le secteur touristique en
europe représente à lui seul 10% du pib
de l'union européenne 12 % des emplois
ça vaut aussi pour la france qui aura
besoin de cette manne
touristique est ce que vous ne souhaitez
pas tout de même pour les compatriotes
français de pouvoir ouvrir justement les
frontières est remonté un peu la pente
cet été mais bien évidemment mais je
pense que ce qu'on ne mesure pas
aujourd'hui c'est un impact du tourisme
français ou franco français avec
beaucoup de gens qui avaient pour
habitude ou qui avait d'ailleurs projeté
peut-être quelques mois de partir à
l'étranger si jean la semence
probablement se se se développer dans
dans l'eure dans leurs projets en france
donc je pense qu'on va avoir
certainement j'espère de bonnes
surprises notamment sur les zones vertes
d'ailleurs de la carte de france sur les
zones qui eux
aujourd'hui on voit ici à endiguer un
petit peu la propagation du virus donc
bien sûr nous souhaitons que les
restaurateurs que les acteurs du
tourisme play l'hôtellerie que les
agences de voyages tout ces gens là qui
ont énormément souffert pendant ces deux
derniers mois
eh bien nous souhaitons bien sûr que
l'île puisse réactive et bien sûr leur
profession cependant attention nous
sommes là aussi pour assurer la sécurité
s'ils étaient les français il s'agit pas
de produits ou de provoquer une seconde
vague ou une troisième palme pense
qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont
suffisamment sérieux discipliné cela
n'arrive pas bien
une fois plus nous ne remontons
fermeture des frontières
je répète la fermeture des frontières ça
ne veut pas dire même pas pouvoir
on nous pose toujours le contrôle des
frontières la fermeté les frontières ne
souhaitons pas un repli sur nous-mêmes
compare parfois certains adversaires et
c'est nous qui a duré nous souhaitons
contrôle et nous souhaitons réguler mais
ryan porte elle souffre elle se ferme
elle souffre grandement où elle se ferme
c'est comme cela que nous souhaitons
demain pouvoir continuer à voir gérer je
répète les flux de personnes comme de
marchandises
c'est le rôle d'un pays doit être m en
cette matière là donc je souhaite bien
sûr que le tourisme ne se développe je
souhaite que tous ces acteurs d'une
superbe longue que toutes les
entreprises puissent se relever mais
c'est à l'écart aussi à prendre ses
dispositions
merci beaucoup aux gens la halakha pas
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
français voulaient